[Music]
if you look at them the history of what
happened to Darwin when he published
what would you call that yes he was
hugely attacked at the time and it's
often a case of people do not want to
give up their cherished beliefs
especially cherished beliefs that they
find comforting so it's no good for
Richard Dawkins to say you know let us
stand on the bold bear promontory of
truth and you know acknowledge the
basically nothingness of ourselves and
people people don't find that cozy so
they will go around the block not to do
that and that's very understandable in
human and religious thinking you know
the idea that there's somebody bigger
than you out there who might be helpful
to you if certain rules are observed
that goes back so far it's probably we
probably have an epigenetic luster of
epidemis
that and you see it a lot in small
children you know there there is there
is a monster under the bed
but and and you can't tell them there
isn't that they don't find that
reassuring what you can tell them is yes
there is a monster under that bed but as
long as I put this this cabbage right in
this spot it can't come out
so yes anti science when science is
telling you something that you really
find very inconvenient and that is the
history of global warming and the
changes that we are certainly already
seeing around us first of all it was
denial and it cannot be happening
there's grudging admission as things
flood and and droughts kick in and food
supplies drop and the same level rises
there and the glaciers melt big-time I
have seen that been there you can't deny
that it's happening but you then have to
pretend that it's nothing to do with us
so so therefore nothing so we don't have
to change our behavior that's the
thinking around that and that can get
very entrenched until people see that by
trying to solve the problem jobs can be
created and money can be made and that
will be the real tipping point in in
public consciousness in this country
other countries are already there Norway
which is an oil state is a huge green
country because they know that the
fossil fuel thing is going to run out so
they are already preparing for that and
if we were at all forward-looking more
of us wouldn't be doing that although
Elon Musk is wave of the future
he's got the all-electric car he's got
the rapid recharger for it and he's got
the powerwall
which is a home battery storage unit
that you can recharge through solar and
then run your appliances off it when
it's dark and that is probably going to
be the the connecting link when that
becomes cheap enough and efficient
enough you ask anybody I don't care who
they are if you could get off the grid
and have a car you can recharge yourself
and appliances you could run yourself
just off some units on your on your roof
or in your backyard would you do that
everybody says yes so that's the idea
who's his time has come and now it's a
matter of the price so mentalizing the
entire world with with
turbines is not going to be the answer
it's going to be individually owned and
controlled off the grid electrical
systems
[Music]